we just gotta have a moment for sharpay
she is truly a pop culture icon that is
still so relevant in 2021. are we clear
yes ma'am i mean sharpay and he's
talking to you evaporate tall person
absolutely
not is there a part of you that ever
thinks about revisiting that character
maybe re visiting her with a more adult
approach i don't know i just feel like i
wouldn't be able to
do that again and give it justice you
know i'm saying like i think at that
moment in time i was very unaware of
myself and my surroundings and i feel
like that's a big part of sharpay like
she's just like not really aware
and so as i grew up and became more
aware i think that it's just something
that it wouldn't be the same and i am
one of those people that like when
something was just like a moment in time
it's like just leave it there it's so
good and it's like for me i would hate
to ruin something that is perfect for
that moment and i don't think i could go
back to it oh gosh okay well i
completely respect that i have to let
you know though as a fan though i don't
think you'd ever ruin anything
i would love to see maybe sharpay's a
mom today maybe she's had some dating
woes of her own that we could explore
yes yeah
it just makes sense i know that you're
you're huge on social media do you
encounter yourself as much as we do i'm
constantly seeing sharp pay gifts and
reaction memes and things of that sort
of no i don't i honestly don't see that
at all
it looks like an algorithm is probably
pointing out stuff to you that maybe
you're looking at things like that no i
honestly don't see myself very much okay
then we're obviously looking at very
different things because at least once a
day i'll see something like evaporate
tall person or a hair flip you know
she's just such a vibe in such a mood
it's wild to me that you never see
anything i see a lot of my old red
carpet i see that stuff pop up on
people's like on memes and stuff and
i'll be like oh my gosh where's some
friends we'll send it that's been
popping up a lot more um the y2k bastion
when you think back on all the
incredible red carpet appearances you've
done especially from that y2k era is
there one look that really stands out as
just being the one like that you can't
seem to shake loose people always want
to ask you about it probably
the incredibles premiere it's like the
one where i'm wearing the
fur thing like the fake fur that
crumbles my chest i just remember i was
being dressed by my stylist from the
sweet life of zach and cody for these
events and so that is a very disney way
of dressing like on our show it works
because it's like funky in the character
but obviously just does not translate on
the red carpet i do remember being like
i want to look like a superhero and that
was the outfit
and honestly how i'm posed in the
picture it looks like i'm a cardboard
cutout and so i just like die laughing
every single time i see it i even joke
being like met gala you know 2020 or
something like it's just so ridiculous
it's so funny so those those definitely
pop up for me i love that you have such
a great sense of humor about it but when
we think about your discography be good
to me is in constant rotation it's a
pregame staple over here
[Music]
is there a throwback song that you are
just like it's so near and dear to your
heart and is there one that you're like
i think i'd be okay if i never sang that
one again he said she said i would say
it's very near and dear because it was
really like my first single as a solo
artist
[Music]
i remember just being like i just dreamt
of having a trl number one music video
when i was younger and watching trl back
in the day and i did get a number one
tier on music video for he said she said
so that was like a really exciting
moment for me what if is a song that's
on my second album it was like one of
the first songs i co-wrote and i feel
like i was just so new at co-writing
that i'm like
[Music]
[Applause]
i think you can like really tell
especially with my last album symptoms i
co-wrote every single song on the album
and so it's amazing to see like the
growth of what obviously with doing it
more and being more confident in my
writing how that's changed so i would
say you know probably yeah what if was
one of those songs i was like eh but it
was like still something that was
exciting because it was one of the first
that co-wrote for sure i hope you never
stop performing he said she said live no
matter how successful you get no matter
how much your music changes please
always keep that one in rotation
it's been so inspiring to watch you and
your empire really evolve and grow
obviously you're an actress and a singer
but you've really dived headfirst into
interior design and blogging and this
whole mom chapter of your life as you
continue to expand the ashley tisdale
brand
how much of a role will acting and music
play because it really seems like you're
in this very entrepreneurial phase of
your life yeah i mean i i definitely
have always
you know loved being creative and i
think that frenchie lets me have that
creative outlet especially being home
and working from home and then also with
interior design and that's also
something but i think that i don't know
if music will have a big you know
thing in my life but acting is always
number one i think that for me i'm at
that point where i'm like if i'm gonna
take time away from jupiter it's gonna
be because it's like something that's so
different for me and exciting and
inspiring and with that perspective and
that clarity that you seem to have now
at 36 is there something that you wished
you would have known when your career
really exploded you know in your your
early 20s thanks to you know high school
musical i know olivia rodrigo who you're
a huge fan of she's kind of going
through that right now is there
something that you wished you would have
known about life and the media and
navigating all of it i don't know i feel
like i did a pretty good job at getting
through it
so you did i think it's just like
staying grounded i think staying
grounded and being a good person in life
i think that that's the most important
thing to me is being a good person you
know i feel like uh there are so many
times where you hear the story of of you
know someone just kind of like losing
themselves in that and um it's hard to
come back after that once you've lost
yourself so i feel like as long as you
stay grounded and grateful for the
opportunities and just try your best and
that's all you can do
[Music]
you